ladies and gentlemen director Angley and
producer Jerry Bruckheimer I really
can't believe we pulled this one off
this is fantastic I just want to start
by saying how thankful I am for the two
of you doing this QA with us been a fan
of both of yours for a very very long
time and I'm super super excited that
you guys joined us for the screening
before we get started I want to give a
huge thank you to Paramount Pictures for
letting a screen Gemini man before it's
in theaters huge thank you and also a
huge thank you to IMAX for being a
fantastic partner and for allowing us to
screen in 3d - ray before I started the
movie I mentioned to the audience that
the high frame rate who in this audience
would saw high frame rate tonight for
the first time okay so was it like I
said at the beginning instead of looking
at a movie screen it was like looking
through a window would you guys agree or
disagree was it was it crazy for you
guys to see it like this
[Laughter]
Before we jump into Gemini man I have a
few what I call fun questions for the
two of you I promise they're harmless
I'll find out in about three minutes if
they hate them but hopefully they won't
Jerry what TV show would you love to
guest produce an egg what TV show would
you love to guest direct guest direct I
don't know I've never tried TV is there
a TV show that you're watching right now
that you would love to know that okay
say no more look I just love the shows
we have on the air that's it
I accept that by the way if people don't
realize Jerry has about 72 shows on TV
I'm slightly exaggerating but not really
besides your movies what movie have you
seen the most I think David Lean is some
of the I've seen his movies are a number
of times I love his work Bridge on the
River Kwai Lawrence of Arabia so those
are Godfather there is another movie
I've seen a number of times
papa probably I would say Billy Wilder
since I was 12 I just know it's this
person I remember the movie I saw his
movie before and when I was little then
when I get older I'll just grab whatever
I can even before that I just love the
man is there do you guys own any movie
or TV show prompts
I'm not a big collectors a few things I
have to collect like I don't know how
many of you seeing the ice storm that
key ball will throw the key in that
destroys so many families when I collect
that key ball the plastic ball
I kept the the sword from present a
green dragon that Green Destiny sword
I designed it so I kept it and also the
bad woman who lets have that Evo
stickler sword and the stick and poison
powder so I kept that prop and I kept
from the hoch that a hair fryer the
thing catches split back and blow up I
like what you said you're not a
collector you still have a few things
just throw that out there do you own any
I have too many to tell you is there I
keep things from every movie uh there's
been a lot of movies do you have like a
full storage unit that people would be
like losing their mind to walk through
no but I have these showcases that I
have a lot of the props in I've actually
you won't remember this but I went to
your office once and I remember seeing
cool things there I'll just say it like
that no we have a lot we saved some of
the key things from all of our movies
what what films scared you as a kid
psycho that's how old I am it's going
way back by the same director bird good
and it gets scary as scary as I grow
older it gets more perverse was a little
bit more about female sexual psychology
it's even scarier what jumping backwards
what do you remember what it was when
you were growing up that said I want to
work in the entertainment industry I
want to direct I want to produce
do you remember was her a performance or
a movie or something that clicked that
said I really want to do this well for
me it was just I loved the experience of
going to films I just loved it you know
having my hand in my popcorn and sitting
back there and getting lost in somebody
else's world I had no idea how you could
do that how he could be part of it I
grew up in Detroit and there was a no
connection to Hollywood whatsoever other
than that you know I read everything I
could and try to figure out how I would
fit into that world and somehow I got
here started doing it so I got very
lucky for me it was when I was 18 the
first and a student stage I failed the
college examination and I got into
Academy of art so I was all in shame I
was trying to start my life all over
again and
maybe I do the next year's entrance
examination but once that super on stage
I remember something lights like this I
just feel the audience in a dark beyond
the lights and I felt like I belong
there that was the pivotal moment for me
and I always associate Gil with the
pleasure of standing on stage or
performing art or even making movies you
two have done some huge films films that
are beloved by many many people when
they meet you is there one or two things
that people always want to talk to you
about or is it sort of like in certain
areas of the world people are more
likely to talk to you about a certain
thing you know I it's it's funny because
there we've made so many movies and it
depends on the age if they're young they
want to talk about pirates if they're
older they like to talk about Top Gun or
Beverly Hills Cop so or if they're in
the military they want to talk about you
know some Black Hawk Down or you know it
all depends where you are in your life
and that's what gravitates them to
certain movies that I've produced for me
is the movie touched them extent
Sensibility Crouching Tiger Hidden
Dragon in China they like the ease they
like to talk about a life of Pi for some
reason it inspired their imagination or
something touched them deeply usually
out Brokeback Mountain I get a lot I'm
into my life thank you and wedding
banquet thank you when did you two first
meet did you did you ever meet before
this project to ever talk about working
together I don't think so no so can you
just shotgun marriage
so I'm curious can you I am I met David
Ellison in his office he called me wants
to meet me about this movie that was
guidance so he pitch me idea a click
right away see a young Will Smith and
digital person I said would you support
the high frame rate 3d I think to me
that's normal frame right if you want to
see 3d he said his attack a guy so say
yeah yeah yeah and Jerry's producing it
I said come come to my office I show you
a real ability and see if you really
want to get into it so that's the first
time I saw him they all come from LA to
New York to my office and I showed him a
real appeal in and they say we're in
that that's the first time I saw this
this man is the legendary man but is
there Jerry this project has been in I'm
gonna use the term development hell for
a very long time what was it when did
you realize this can finally get made I
would say it's about three years ago we
figured out we watched some of the
de-aging that they've been doing some
stuff that Marvel has been doing in
other films and we did a little bit of
it ourselves so we we saw that the
technology was very close so the project
wasn't really in development all that
long it was sitting on a shelf because
we did it early on when we got the
project about I don't 10 12 years ago we
did a bunch of tests and it was awful I
mean really awful we just knew we
couldn't do it so we just put it down
and waited and we brought in David
Benioff who I'm sure you guys know and
he came in and did a rewrite and that
kind of sparked the excitement again I'm
about three or four years ago and that
got it started again and then we took it
over to skydance and David Ellison he
read it he said I want to make this and
I think he'd had scheduled a meeting
with an to pitch him some projects and
and kind of like this one I'm curious
you've worked with Will Smith a few
times is it as simple to get him in a
movie as you texting him or is how much
convincing does it take coming from you
you know I think every actors is you
know get they all get the big ones got
offered everything
because they movie gets made When Will
Smith says yes I'm gonna do the movie
unless it's you know usually expensive
that's a different issue but so
everybody's pulling on his coattails you
know read me see me you know be in my
film so we just stand in line like
everybody else and try to get our day in
court but he likes the kind of stuff
that we make and produce and we have a
great relationship with him and he was a
really big fan of and I had nothing to
do with me he liked the material and
loved dang I had nothing to do with it
so that was great for us
for the two of you the the high the 3d
high frame rate in this is the best I've
ever seen in terms of the high frame
rate while I enjoyed Billy Lynn's high
frame rate I just for me this is it's
even better can you talk about the
technology where it's at now and how you
were able to pull this off because it
looks in that high frame rate 3d it's
it's unbelievable I learned a lot from
both Life of Pi and it's long halftime
walk especially Berlin so I just learned
that I just get better at this point for
that did you that one I want to make a
comparison I want to get rid of what we
think movie is that was like the task
over Berlin the result is it's not all
that successful but I was very proud of
many thing I found this beauty in 3d
we've give sufficient information I also
understand we don't really know 3d we
haven't even started yet this is a new
media it's a new engagement with the
theatrical experience it's not always in
but you can still go out and in it seems
to be something else and from fiddling I
realized with two eyes come to a point
is just you're processing image
differently that's why you feel
immersive but your mind also racing
faster you're sharper like in real life
you detect things you gather
informations somehow differently that's
why you need higher framerate because
the two eyes has to
aligned with each other and agree with
each other it seems to be a different
world out there to me billion I use a
war movie to compare with halftime show
to see the contrast and for this one I
just determined I just want to make it
look pretty people say it's like a giant
TV is not it's just something people
never seen before and this is giant TV
maybe look like that so I was determined
to make it look really pretty but
realistic at the same time so finding
there a real location that looks pretty
and we also I think more successful in
this one than billion a lot of time I
think 3d should have its own lighting
because you're giving to mention you
don't have to throw those shadows you
don't have to do separation in principle
you should light it differently and you
should light for details and more
surrounding so we really try this and
now that you might notice is the the
nice scenes I wrote a lot of nice things
you probably didn't know why I did that
but but I wrote a lot of nice things
just to see how lighting works and also
expose it differently because at night
we see details but in movies you don't
but with this media you just want
because it's so much like life we want
it to look like life so you do want to
see details so I shot a lot of them
during the day and I still let them and
treat him in the post and tweak the
color and try to find a politically
viable nice things and this is also
involving digital moviemaking
so when I talk about digital human the
aging I was very much it was the hardest
thing to do actually to me it's not the
aging is recreate that character from
zero up because by D you brush away a
lot of details which this kind of media
really wants to see d-mail you're happy
when you supply a plenty of information
I think your eyes just happier you're
more relaxed you're more focused so
there you go I think I just learned a
lot from
the past experience in terms of using 3d
language I was more sure what equivalent
where you certain land certain depth
certain width of separation how that
equivalent to how I feel how I would
express I'm still waiting for audience
to tell me how they feel so I'm still
learning also he picked the most
difficult way to do it because you know
there's a lot less information on the
screen when you shoot it at 24 frames
and to create junior you could see every
glint in his eye where if he shot it at
24 there's motion blur
there's grain it covers a lot of the
details that could have your I think
it's a fake so by doing it this way he
made it 5 times harder to create juniors
so that's the mastery of what he has
pulled off to create this human being a
completely digital based on wills
performance so it's it's quite an
accomplishment woody what Aang did I
have a whole bunch of questions about oh
sorry I have a ton of questions about
jr. but I want to actually ask a
specific question about the cameras can
you talk about the cameras you used and
I believe you said the other day that it
was like you were learning on the job -
in terms of the cameras getting better
on the shoot yeah it was really
interesting because I'm not a techno
nerd at all and so I kept watching these
first of all these camera there rigs are
enormous we had to go to Germany to get
special rigs made and we barely got
those rigs in time to start shooting the
movie it took so long to get him made
and there were 20 wires coming out of
the back of those cameras maybe more 30
they were just wires everywhere and as
the movie progressed there were less and
less wires so they kept creating better
way to shoot the movie I think at the
end they were like seven wires going
into the camera and so I think this
medium will evolve and the cameras will
get smaller and there'll be less wires
and much easier to to operate and use
also it was so difficult the cameras
were so heavy that we we wanted to do
handheld it was really a chore for for
our handheld operators so it what and
and the grips design they designed these
bungee cords on on like rollers and it
was just fascinating to see what they
did so you could move around with these
cameras and they kind of bounce up and
down as we moved them so it was it was
really a technological feat what you saw
on the screen it looks so simple and
easy
it wasn't thanks though Ahri's they
created seven cameras for us that's half
the size that I come down hundred 24 K
therefore we need because the camera is
smaller because we have to shoot actions
it have to be smaller so we have to
develop the new rigging that's smaller
as well and the wires just I don't know
there's so many people working I don't
know what they do they all look serious
and busy looking at some kind of monitor
like three ten full of people wherever I
go it's just endless wires and meters
and you know everybody's so busy
how did shooting in this format with
these cameras affect your shooting
schedule does it amplify it by a certain
percentage or by the end you sort of
figure out a way to make it work in the
normal timeframe
well I think we we figure out a way to
work make it work but it was very tough
on Aang because in the beginning it
didn't always work the way 100 it'll
work so you always had breakdowns where
one of the eyes were off and had to
start all over again or the camera would
break down we had to send cameras home
it was yeah there were all kinds of
issues but he stayed on his shooting
schedule he just had less coverage and
less time to direct the scenes but as
you see did a masterful job and I must
say it really take a seasoned director
to do this to decide what exactly have
the shoe sometimes we might shoot like
two shots a day in action we we don't
have coverages really well the shots
there may be a shots a day eight to ten
shots that's really minimum for action
movies Michael Bay
would shoot 4250 setup so today and he'd
use every one of them in some way we're
expensive big movie but it's like poor
then steal them films like really really
strange in like I definitely want to
jump into creating jr. talk a little I
mean what you had to do to bring this
performance to life is is crazy talk a
little bit about what will was basically
there was another actor there and then
will would recreate the performance
could you sort of talk about how it was
brought to life I'll do it poorly
Englund do too much better but there was
really three wills there was the first
will who used for his body type and his
skin he was young and handsome and so he
always was acting against Henry and then
we'd have a stuntman in the action stuff
replace our handsome guy and then we'll
would then do every scene all over again
by himself for the acting part in in a
head rig and pajamas with all the dots
on them so angular 3 times to get what
you saw on the screen the hardest part
of creating believable when jr. is
science is hard enough the study on
Aging what it does and that's to a
person and how do you make a lively
person look like is alive that's really
hard but the really hard stuff comes
after everything is perfect that's when
your work started how we perceive Will
Smith how we think he can play kindly in
a better acting today a young man with
innocence which is kind of a different
kind of a character than how we remember
in at this age range and all those
things each time the scene changed life
changed angle change somehow
just doesn't look like him or it doesn't
look right we'll check his own movie
let's say we take them bad boys half the
shots don't look like him but you don't
care because you know it's real but with
the digital we we don't really want to
believe because we know it's not true so
you're really fighting with the viewers
perception and that's kind of a
whimsical and when we watch 3d the
difference between people are much
larger than 2d so even to our filmmakers
like the top head of Department will
watch a shot we can have very different
opinions so you just go over and over
and over and over until we feel like I
think that's when Smith when it's young
and performing like this yeah they're
over five hundred artists working on
this yeah five hundred people spend a
year post actually they start working on
a well and shoot I have to give them
producers and studio a lot of credit
because they allow us to turn over while
we're shooting before we lock the cuts
because these fans start to spend real
money we come me too even we don't know
what at the end of it what it really
looks like and they're already spending
money cuz it would really need all that
time it's just time and effort time ever
I hate to call it technology because
technology only go this far the red is
like artistic endeavor like hundreds of
people's keep going and I keep going at
it
guessing and trying guessing and trying
scratching our heads I wasn't even sure
himself if he could pull it off he said
I'm pretty confident but I really don't
know we can do this what kind of sold
all of us is he took a scene from bad
boys and it's will and Martin in a car
and they're talking and he took one of
the head shots of will and replaced it
with a digital we'll just one shot and
you watch the scene and I couldn't pick
out the shot that he changed into a
digital head so that gave us the
enormous amount of confidence and him
too I think
egg felt pretty good about what happened
one of the things about will is that
he's I think 50 but he looks so much
younger how is that as a how challenging
is it to make him look do you know what
I mean because he looks young well we
put some gray hair we had he we put gray
hair on him made him look a little older
we try different ways to do that but if
you do the study compared then even
we'll who's kept himself so well you see
the difference you see the difference
right the age start something that was
in twenty thirty years yeah and you have
to understand that the people in Wetty
had to reconstruct his whole face that
from the muscles to the pores on his
skin that was all done with their artist
it's just amazing what they accomplished
they had a skeleton view of his head and
they started adding muscles and
everything to his face and how the eye
moves how the mouth moves what muscles
move the mouth and the eyes and think
the eyes are even the teeth change
collar over their years subtle things
like that a corner of the eyes even
every teacher ever how does that move
relating to the emotion relating to
aging it's mind-boggling the study that
get into it is freeze layers of skins
you can see through him every pool is
like so much detail the study on will
there's mind-boggling what shot were
shots did you continually go back to
because you were never satisfied it's
the first shot I was very nervous the
first real shot of him in my plane
people was the motorcycle fight in
here's the sunglasses on though it's in
broad daylight is action so I want
audience to get used to these existence
except him
I think that's easier the shot really
concerns me is when he sit on a bed
talking to his dad that's the whole
thing is in one shot I did a like a 180
degree kind of care
that's pretty scary the whole scenes one
shot and that if I can anchor that I
think people are going along with him so
that's the anchor shot for me that took
up after we shot it and turn it in it
took about a year first shot of turn in
and last had to come up I'm definitely
curious to talk about the editing
process because so much happens
in the editing room talk a little bit
about your first cut compared to the
finished film and how much changed along
the way if at all you know this is a new
look so I'm nervous about it you know
how people are accepted and then we have
Will Smith in a big action movie and
personally I like to do drama and on
something you don't see for a year you
know I have that cut out with will that
funny face with the jumpsuit with
heading and gear with the camera here
and full of a thoughts on his face and
white spots and we watch that for a long
time and try to judge if the movie is
moving or working or not it's kind of
unfair but that's all we have and as we
go in further into that we see more
shots by animation by really rough in it
so it's very hard for for editing and we
tested it's a long process we kept
changing then we have a little bit of
reshoot and finally we you know finally
kind of see everything then we felt we
need to reshoot a little bit she don't
process that's like every movie yet the
additional photography is every movie
yeah what you find out is no matter how
many people read the script and approve
the script the audience is much smarter
than we are
they really are and they'll see things
that we didn't get at all and we have a
lot of really smart people working at
least movies but the audience is always
somehow a lot smarter than we are
oh I was gonna say that I'm always
fascinated by what was the last thing
that you cut out before you picture
locked if you can remember picture lock
meaning like when they lock the movies
you can't make any more changes there's
one scene
Jerry probably don't want to cut out
because they're shooting the father at
the end was very unsettling I think to
the audience I think we need a lighter
scene so we have Mary arrest that bad
woman Lassiter Pat pause as the
satisfaction is a very light scenes it's
try to light things up a little bit then
we go to the ending that wasn't a
particularly good scene but it's sort of
you sort of need that to lighten things
up a little bit
unfortunately we reshoot the ending that
does light things up and as a warm
ending so we took that I think that's
the last thing we took out yes
Thanks so how does the high frame rate
the 3d effect the way you shoot a movie
do you are you are you on set and being
aware that you cannot do as many cuts or
are you filming it a certain way knowing
from what you've learned on Billy Lynn
and you put into this
I think this media like me zone say more
than cutting the montage mino-san is how
you arrange in the same shot how do you
move things around
how are you staging it I think that's
because you're in it I don't want to
disrupt it with too many cuts although
all the cast still work you just have to
be aware of the z-axis changes are eyes
adjusting it's a much slower then left
or right up and down so other than that
just about all the shots all the cuts we
used to do all work but I think when you
do that you're not taking advantage of
this media this media is beautiful we
have a
to see a lot of detail in one shot and
the shots can go longer and you can it
can really take advantage of that so I
do take longer shots I took master shots
very seriously imagine that would be the
shot and I was sort of assembled a movie
together instead of Kali together of
course being professional I have to do
coverage kind of a minimum coverage just
in case that doesn't work this movie you
never know so you have somewhere to go
and there are times master shot work
great but then you go to a close out
actor give you something great there's
no way you're not using a close shot
when actors are great so I do pretty
minimum coverage I would say but I'll
still cover it but I do pay attention to
the beauty shots and the longer shots
and make sure it'll really go way out
when I did to the movies before white
shot and master Sha's seems to be
oriented just get tuning training actors
to get into the situation or somewhere
if you need to reorient your audience
you just cut back to the wider shot
otherwise you just go in and an end
that's how we usually make movies but
with this I pay special attention to
master shots I was gonna say that both
of you guys
I'm sure pre-planned so much on this
movie but there had to have been a day
or two on set where you got hit with
challenges you were completely not
expecting do you remember any of those
every day I will say it three times a
day yeah
every day something would break or
someone go wrong it's it's so
complicated this camera system there's
so many things that can just go haywire
on you and I mean he's not kidding when
we had like three or four tents with
technicians working behind the scenes to
make sure everything was was going right
like heat one of the technicians run out
tang and say oh the IO is off you know
left
wrong and so we'd have to redo the scene
and correct it and sometimes it the one
of the cameras will go down and and we
had to wait till II we got another
camera put it into the rig or sometimes
we didn't have another camera so it was
there was always a remote control the
the focus polling doesn't quite work it
was too slow or this just that always
something I don't want to discourage
anybody making this kind of movie it's
just difficult now someday we'll be like
you know cameras this size of an ice
cube and film still then we'll be
knowing that before I get out of school
all the language no just a week to
account but to us is really difficult it
will get easier easier easier if you've
seen pictures of the movies that were
made in 30s and 40s and you saw the size
of those cameras they were just just
enormous and look what we're using today
the cameras about this big
cinematographer each time I get in
despair or get frustrated here's
something putting my off is one of those
camera it's the size of two
refrigerators with like 30 people
standing around it and I thought huh
we're not that bad I am I am curious
though at the beginning of the shoot did
you find that there were more technical
challenges and by the end because
earlier you mentioned that you had the
wires cut down to like seven did you
find at the end of the shoot that the
cameras were more reliable and you were
having less technical hurdles absolutely
I mean we flew out technicians from
Germany to work on the cameras to figure
out we're having moisture problems in
the cold and in the heat some of the
cameras would go down they had to figure
out what the problem was and they did
they came in and they reworked the
cameras and changed them and brought new
ones in and by the end it was a lot
smoother operation not only equipments
and technician - like the focus puller
for example with training for two months
this is like the best in the business
at Trent two months and I kept warning
and when you really do it it's not it's
not what you're thinking
yeah yeah it's you know be respectful
but yeah yeah
first shot in the movie we watched it
daily so what did I tell you this it's
that bonsai trees you just don't know
where your eyes are going it's like
really tricky and it freaked out and for
like months he would come every shadow
come to my booth check the 3d and watch
that day leaves diligently and try to
get it the time when he really get it
cuz for the last movie nobody knows how
we pull focus this is like really
difficult because the information you're
attacking it along with so much and then
your eyes are so tricky it's so critical
it's not like who is speaking you go
where your eyes do strange things you
don't know what's more interesting and
where you're staying and you have to
like super then with families you have
to be super aggressive like before will
is about to do that even I know before
even will knows he knows like I beat him
like quarter of a second there's some
tricks
finally it take him like two months to
get it's really difficult but once you
get it it can hype like this it's very
exciting it's interesting you're saying
that this is the best in the business
and he's having a nervous breakdown
you know but I would imagine by the end
of the shoot though it sounds to me it
would be easy in the future but it's
difficult now there's a lot of R&D on
this one how does it work with in the
editing room with shooting 120 frames a
second in the 3d how does that change
the editing equipment that you're using
how many computers you need like how
does it change the whole post-production
process our area is really a scientist
him and I we work every every movie I
made I think we're the first ones you
use avid computer from wedding Bengal is
lighting 91-92
we're the guinea pigs because people are
let us use it and try which one to
invest them and they give us free
equipment so you hardly can see anything
that's
how we edited so he would grow together
with the editing equipment we can edit a
60 frame per second that's how we do it
well too bad my editor style here I'm
like a really low tech person but what's
special
after Life of Pi really and this we work
pretty swiftly it's complicated but it's
pretty handy and pretty handy the the
big difference that there's no lab to
process our material like to see dailies
to go day by day business so we have our
own labs so that's special it's a huge
room and you know I don't know how many
terrible terabytes me they're carrying
so that enormous room for the 3d
equipment to see dailies and it had to
be freezing cold and there's so that's
really strong conditioners in there yeah
we have our own lab it's um it's my last
question before I open it up for the
audience what do you think the VFX in
this are crazy what do you think for the
two of you is the next thing that
Hollywood can overcome with VFX already
let me actually stick with that I want
to say turning major effects to visual
art it's a artistic approach you touch
up you do digital moviemaking
so people they're not thinking about the
effects they just watch the movie and it
becomes unnoticeable
what is the fantasy or realistic movie
you improve the quality of how we
pretend something happens I think
digital we call them facts I really
don't like in fact I think they're great
tools when we do digital film with their
great tool to touch out to help to make
believe they're anything that you well
you know based on what you see now we
can do just about anything whatever a
writer can imagine we can figure out how
to do
and that is all new I mean Marla
wouldn't be marbled without the
technology that we've created through
the years we they couldn't make those
movies they could have made them but the
digital effects would have been there
weren't digital effects so it wouldn't
have looked the way it looks today
and as the computer power keeps every
four or five months it doubles and
triples which gives us more and more
information or more ways of doing things
so we're pretty much at a place right
now where you create something you put
something on a page and angle figure out
a way to bring it to an audience and the
technicians will be able to do it in
making this kind of movie the 3d movies
when you supply enough informations it's
getting harder and harder to physically
pretend something happens I think
digital help is really helpful and
that's making this kind of movie we
really need it be like a normal part of
moviemaking that's from my perspective
I'm gonna open it up to the audience
where's the ball
there it is so that is the light what's
a cold again the catch catch box that's
right so it's a it's a it's a thing you
can throw at people and it has a
microphone in it let's start right over
there wait I just want to see something
how many people have questions okay so
we're gonna try to do what we call the
lightning round because I want to try to
get as many people in before they tell
me that they have to leave so we're
gonna try to do this quick so everyone
can ask you know what I mean like a
lightning round so right there you got
to talk into the thing I don't know no
but I want to make sure that the filming
can is it on hold on let's see what yeah
I don't think so either
it'll be fixed in two seconds
promise okay let's just call it out
while he's fixing the question for both
of you is what was your favorite scene
in the movie well I think the the
motorcycle chase for me is quite an
accomplishment what what ankled off and
it's very exciting and it really puts
you there you're on that motorcycle with
them and it's pretty thrilling yeah I'm
saying that when Henry wakes up that ten
minutes and the chasing full chase that
lead to the motorcycle that sequence I
can watch it again and again I also like
when I have that confrontation talk to
each other in the catacomb where we see
a lot of it closed off Jr's face that
leads to the fight
I like that sequence too next question
I'm gonna look over right there how did
you pull off the underwater scenes with
the technical challenges of the cameras
I really want to do it because I
imagined it would be so beautiful I have
to do it there's nothing to do with
anything but I really want to see it how
did you do actually this came from Life
of Pi because we under water shots and
at that time nobody take a 3d camera
banging around it's home always in the
control condition like stage and we're
making water movie it's pretty crazy but
for that movie we made the underwater 3d
underwater rigging a case it's a blue
box like very big takes many people to
operate you should see that how we do
handheld shot with that thing it's very
funny
so I underwater I remember that gear so
it called up is still there only after
us probably being used once so we use
that to do the underwater shout again it
took many people like afraid right back
there wait let's see there's a mic hello
okay you said you were learned a lot of
lessons from Billy Lane and other films
you've done what is the most important
lesson you've learned from making this
movie what's the most important message
lesson
like what did you learn a lesson
I think 3d is a different existence is
not just a space I think that is the
world a that is quite different don't
don't don't assume you know that's
listen to me and listen to my my comrade
other people work on the movie I was
very embarrassed each time there's a big
production meeting the first thing I
said this is embarrassing I want to tell
you're not good enough for the job
neither am I so it's something new
always being alarmed as you're in the
process doing something wrong and you're
not aware of it
so you just need that to be the
awareness
that's hardly a lesson it's just like a
cautious thing I learned that movie has
to be fake I fell into this building I
stage a battle singing in a halftime
show to me they're equally compelling
and interesting but it seems like the
world want to see halftime show they
don't want to go to war so I decided I
want to develop the next level or
artifice it seems like movie needs to be
in a special place
giving the realism of this provide for
people engaged you still need
to create a kind of a dreamy thing with
the genre were familiar with it was not
exactly serving the story sometimes it
does sometimes it doesn't and then you
have the biggest movie starting has this
thing that we expect from him and you
have him play something else it's very
challenging it's stretched a lot
sometimes clumpy something sometimes you
feel you hit the sweet spot like yeah
you know but movie is um it's a mystery
I always try to think I know I learned
something there's always beat me some
way I tried a crossing tag in drag I
want to change that and then you yield
to something the next movie I try so no
no I really want to make it their
friends you make that much difference
and then the movie will beat you somehow
something we wrestle with not only my
imagination but audience imagination is
really tricky it's the lesson is harder
than you think so thank you is the ball
is the catch box working or no hi big
fan of both of you for a long time as a
sparring free as an aspiring filmmaker
I'm always curious to see what was the
toughest and easy state like on set I
know that a movie like this or actually
any movies that are very difficult to
make so I'm just curious to see what the
toughest and easiest days was like I
think the toughest days were in carta
Hania when the temperature was peaking
towards a hundred and you're just
exhausted and sweating and it was really
tough and the cameras were breaking down
we had some pretty steamy days the
toughest day was when
a junior throw the bag towards Henry
that they will only do did have a shot
it was a cloudy day was just miserable
nothing looks bright you know under
tremendous time pressure because those
are historical sights and a very busy
tourist you sight would make it look
like like a perfect plague of paradise
like hardly anybody go there that's not
true it's infested with the tourists and
so to lock up a section one day at a
time you know it you don't have a lot of
time you know it's a special favor the
city really hosts start to make things
happen so that day you have if the
weather is bad is wet so that was a bad
day and then no matter how many times we
was sending that bike no practice or
whatever the practice that does his
thing then we broke the the stomach
which is the best biker in the world
like world champion I don't know how
many years like the best in the business
is doing that sliding and sending any
broke his finger and he kind of say okay
we're gonna stop and then can I ask you
today is like nothing work why do I
don't make movie what why would come to
this place that's not a movie town like
I know it's pretty everything goes wrong
he also wanted to know was it was there
ever an easy day I I don't want to say
easy day but I expect something really
hard but I come up a Z so I would say
that's the easiest day for me that's a
will doing jr. seeing that has the final
confrontation with his dad in the office
because that happened to be the third
week was still early it's one of the
earliest seen like only the second scene
was she junior we don't know if will can
be young and this and that and he's
facing a tremendous good actor English
actor Clive Owen so
pressure is very high in the morning
with shot clive sight is like jiménez
and then we're going to lunch and we'll
stay in the trailer 1 or 2 1 hour half
an hour longer why show up I know he's
preparing psych himself out he come out
and with his funny gears that's over his
face and he's just nailing the first
take everything you see that this is a
really compelling see I know it's a
young face it's hearsay
that's all like some day you're seeing
the making of the movie that's all we'll
like exactly what it did and then right
after that I was saved I think oh well
maybe we can take one extra day because
this is a crucial scene before we can
wrap like halfway into the afternoon we
had a couple miserable days in Savannah
they had these bugs called noseeums and
everybody had mosquito netting and head
to toe but they get inside nets and it
got so bad a crew members actually had
to go to the hospital there were so many
bites on them so that was one of our
more miserable days all the people that
think working on movies is luxurious and
glamorous you know I think we're almost
out of time but I know there's a few
well let's go right here wanted to know
if you knew what he did to prepare did
he like watch some of his own work I
mean how would he go back into that
mindset to be you know his sort of
younger self in the rehearse her so time
and even shooting time we talked a lot
we did a lot of preparation in terms of
youthful you have to check his old
movies
I met a collection this is what I like
this is what I don't like
yeah the bad boys some of the bigger
scenes more since we like that make Will
Smith I don't like her for this movie
some like nothing when he's not doing
anything it's not important it's quite
genuine and I also like a lot what he
did in six degrees of separation that's
a great acting piece for him and he was
exactly at 23 so I've met her I know
this telephone seeing where you're I
like this section so I went through that
I went through he was very very generous
about sharing they will speak what makes
Will Smith work kind of tricks to me in
this work that word that was a lot of
fun and then his personal life he share
a lot like the genuine him when it was
younger what he was thinking what is it
going through and because this character
has a military background so he shared
his upbringing it's a military father he
corrupted that family so I asked him to
imitate his father what I know so a lot
of references to to begin with but to
unlearn something using the better skill
actor now you know that's seeing I
mentioned about right after we Travis I
can act like that way you're young he's
a better actor so I don't know what I
keep in being a good actor but at the
same time is it
he has to learn a lot of things he knew
and capture that innocence so he really
that that's a much harder job than play
Henry he's a lovely man really working
hard right before they go into the said
I'll respect their privacy for actors I
think I have a pretty sharp eyes and
also I'm the one who's looking at a 3d
monitor that counts more than what you
really see how he feels or 2d monitor
on the camera that monitor counts so I'm
like the third eye tell me what I see
and he was very cooperative
he really want to act well in this scene
I don't care they don't have to tell me
their secrets and how they you know when
they prepare that a good last moment I
give him room give them full respect
whatever they use I'll see the result as
they're like this or loud or what can be
a chest actors they they're very brave
they use something Deeping here I think
we really want to respect them but I can
tell if it's coming to life or not
especially with this media is there a
mic does anyone ever make you guys both
have such incredible bodies of work that
have so much action in them and the
Academy doesn't recognize stunts or
action design out of all your films what
do you think would be Oscar winner for
action design the Academy doesn't really
go after action design or stunt work and
is there something I guess the way to
say it is is there something from your
thing they should does in in Asia we do
I host that happened to be the chair of
this award Golden Horse that's like pen
Chinese language award as like our
Oscars we had that for I don't know 30
40 years nearly 50 years we always have
that that that's a call to action we
call it Best Choreography action
choreography award I just wanted to know
how do you make a war fast how do you do
it in Asia in terms of who because
there's so many people involved in the
actual stunt sequence there are the
people that design it there are the
stunt performers there designer get the
award that's what I was curious about so
it's the designer of the sequence or
risk their life they don't
the people come up with a bad idea they
get awarded right because that's
something to think about though a lot of
people have talked about should artists
at definitely art yeah a hundred percent
thousand percent our form
I completely agree is there a sequence
from your crazy resume that you think
that if there had been an Oscar that
year for stunt work it would have
something that really stands out for you
I think some of the I mean Michael Bay's
a master at it and he's done so many
movies with me that he I mean a lot of
them are just brilliant what he's done
then Armageddon in Pearl Harbor those
some of those battle scenes in Pearl
Harbor are amazing yeah I mentioned this
to you yesterday of uh of all the movies
you've done did you ever think
Armageddon was going to be the criterion
it's awesome let's call it entertaining
it's sorry for the language I apologize
do you can we do one more do you guys is
at the end wait so one more the flare
the light on the gun those choices to
brighten the scene or where those
specific choices okay and have the
choices I want to make it dark and of
course a clone is a rejuvenation of life
so I want something death around them
what's the best how can find a better
way to metaphorically and visually
inspiring but that place supposed to
have no light source and 3d like lights
they'd really like lights they don't
like the the black we had the character
crashing into it I don't like things to
crash which is one of lesson I learned
in this movie not last one last one I
learned not to use backlight too much
but this one I realized they don't like
black they don't like crushing so to
design that eerie dark feeling also give
excuses to have little shimmering lights
to make the separation yeah thought of
the that the flare and we see the
delight there's supposed to be a small
town light but we take pretty powerful
top of it and our best gaffer is Mary
yeah her job is she did a good job
performing hittin the mark and also
biting she this is quite an artist on
that note I want to say I like the
contrast to I'm sorry that has a cold
touch to a little blue touch to it and
the other has that that orangish which
is a cue for danger each time danger
that's kind of our motif we would go
orange so that that combination also
works so just the flare is not enough so
something cold tone and harsh because
it's like harsh reality with EFE orange
dangers background that was the design I
feel I've interrupted you like 16 times
tonight I'm so sorry I'm so sorry um on
that note I want to give a huge thank
you to Paramount Pictures again for
letting us screen the movie early a huge
thank you to IMAX for being an awesome
partner a huge thank you to Thad and
Dennis for filming the Q&A at Collider
and Orion for taking some pictures but
most of all a massive thank you to
Angley and Jerry Bruckheimer for doing
this QA thank you so thank you so much
thank you that's all I can say is thank
you thank you